[Music]
hi i'm jonathan chung tech lead on the
Google Play console working I'll go to
market tours and I'm here today with my
colleagues Ignacio from the Play
business development team and David
product manager on Play console we are
excited to talk to you about what play
console tools you can take advantage of
when building and managing your games
fact in the last few years the number of
Android players who have installed the
game has more than doubled players from
all around the world and from all
different backgrounds are enjoying an
unprecedented amount of new gameplay
experiences on Android as game
developers this is your chance your
chance to build new experiences to
connect to more players and to find
success in the market whether you're a
new developer building your first game
or seasoned veteran of the industry the
opportunity is yours to grasp that being
said with opportunity comes a degree of
risk games development on mobile is an
ever-changing landscape and play
expectations on mobile games has never
been higher there's more competition
than ever before in the marketplace
there are ready 1 billion 1 million
games live on the Play Store and new
games are launching all the time on
Google Play development costs are
increasing due to the demands for higher
fidelity on mobile games and consumers
are expecting more feature-rich
experiences on mobile
finally marketing games is getting
increasingly more difficult
usik recession spending is increasing as
developers are moving towards fewer
larger launches in a single year at
Google Play we understand these problems
and want to help you where we can to
bring as much
yes as possible to your games we are
committed to building tools to help you
plan and deras your launches and to help
you maintain and support your games
after successful launch let us take you
on the journey from pre to post launch
which will hopefully provide some
insights into the some of the exciting
tools we have available for you we will
be covering some existing tools share
some interesting anecdotes and best
practices and show some new tools which
we feel will help you on your road to
success first pre launch this face is
critical for making sure you are
delivering the right experience for your
players what did that be in the gameplay
experience itself the stability and
performance of your game or in the
content roadmap you have planned we're
going to be going through some areas of
focus during pre-launch and also walk
through some of these tours we feel are
helpful at this stage first and perhaps
most importantly testing it is crucial
to get your testing strategy right when
launching a new game as you know
launching and maintaining games as
expensive proposition it is critical to
make sure that when you launch your
product it will be stable and bug free
resonate with your plays from a gameplay
perspective and have a sustainable
roadmap to keep your place invested in
your game and ternal testing allows you
to publish and distribute your apks in
seconds instead of hours so you can push
your daily builds your team immediately
it also features integrations of our api
and other third-party plugins such as
grade or finally it benefits from all
the Google Play products you come to
love such as in that product support
country targeting LVL and of course the
newly announced Android app bundle
developers are using this new track that
you wrap it iterative testing for
launching new games as well as for
adding features to existing games for
instance using it to push their daily
bills to QA in order to make sure the
releases meets their bar for quality or
using it to push experimental builds to
a group of friends and colleagues in
order to play test new gameplay
mechanics here are some things to think
about when using internal testing it's a
great opportunity to focus on stability
and bugs in order to judge every release
against your bar for quality if possible
it can also be useful to start testing
and the wide variety of devices so that
when you decide to roll out two more
players you can certain they will
receive the quality gameplay experience
that you will want them to receive one
of our most used feature of a game
developers is closed testing close
testing is a great opportunity to build
a tight-knit community of testers who
will be able to provide you with
valuable feedback before and after
launch users can be invited directly
from the play console using email lists
or Google Groups they can then opt-in
via web app as shown in this picture
once opted in they can restore the game
directly from the Play Store over 60% of
game developers on play already used
this feature and have found great
success with it let's take a quick look
at a case study Bravo Co where the game
forces of freedom really took to heart
the philosophy of building a strong
tester community for their closed tests
they focused on recruiting the right
sort of players even reaching beyond the
usual online communities to find the
sort of player they felt would have the
affinity with a theme of their game
which is a military shooter game as you
can see in this picture they went to
this s offer event and recruited players
on site to play their game
during the testing period
Bravo Co made sure that they were
available 24/7 by social media and
especially instant messaging this
allowed them not only to gather a very
specific valuable feedback but also to
build connections with individual
testers of their game this dedication to
building a strong tester community paid
off dividends both during testing and
even after launch in early access where
forces of freedom has now attracted more
than 10 million players and Counting in
conclusion here are some things to think
about when using closed testing create a
strong and diverse tester community
remember these players will be critical
in shaping the initial direction of your
game experiment with new gameplay
mechanics and content don't be afraid of
negative feedback remember your ratings
and reviews are still not live at this
point and finally think up think about
reaching out to your testing community
to get a very specific feedback this is
your chance to ask them what works what
didn't work and how do we improve next
open testing once a game is technically
solid and your main gameplay hooks are
built in it's time to think about
expanding your test to more players and
preparation for your big launch open
testing allows your game to be
discoverable installable
on the Play Store and for players up to
a developer defined cap to opt in and
install your game players won't be of
the leave ratings until the game fully
launches but can provide anonymous
feedback to the developer at any time
open testing comes in two flavors
depending on the state of your game if
you don't have a production release
already we're in the same country as you
are running your tests in users will be
able to install your game directly from
the Play Store without needing to opt in
we call this early access your game will
be tagged as unreleased as shown in this
image
if you have a production or release
already for instance you may have
soft-launched in the same country you
can still continue to use open testing
existing users will continue to get
updates on the test track a new users
can opt-in via a console provided web
link or through the card which is shown
on the screen here at the bottom of the
game's details page play is opted into
an open test in this state we'll see the
game tagged as beta so bringing together
these forms of testing of internal tests
and close tests you as the developers
have control over who can install and
play your game early access tests can be
installed and discovered directly from
the Play Store and a great way to expand
your tester base as well as building
hype around your big launch finally open
tests can be used to continue testing
with a wide audience even after your
production release utilize these testers
to try out new features and tweaks to
your game before rolling out to all your
players moving on pre launch reports can
also help developers iron out quality
and performance issues prior to launch
whenever test apk is uploaded a
non-deterministic bot will crawl your
game was running on a real physical
device in one of our test labs game
developers have found a lot of value in
the pre-launch report 90% of developers
don't push the production if the report
shows issues demo loops goes even
further for game developers record and
upload the game demo loop using firebase
test lab and received a PLR report and
crash and performance metrics including
the all-important frames per second this
allows you to discover rendering issues
even faster and launch with greater
confidence Halfbrick games the
developers of titles such as fruit ninja
and jetpack joyride have found great
values in demo loops
they've evolved their QA processes
around using PRA demo loops as allows
them the check for visual glitches
crashes and performance among many other
things they rely on the fact that PLR
will automatically run on a wide range
of devices and device specs for every
test release so how did they do this
Danu game which is an endless runner has
a built-in replay functionality which
they used to record and save interesting
game runs will receive few simple lines
of code they can instrument PLR demo
loops to run on these recorded sessions
whereas before there's a very manual
process to kick off their benchmarking
now where PL our demo loops is automated
for them for every test release they can
look at these metrics and compare them
to every previously race to make sure
that their game has no regressions in
terms of performance before we move over
to launching another important aspect of
pre-launch is a plan your strategy
around content as such don't be afraid
to test longer and the tests earlier
consider using longer term metrics like
D 14 and D 30 in order to predict future
success measure the rate of content
consumption during your testing phase
this can be useful for planning ahead so
that you have enough content for your
players when you launch until your first
big update also this phase is a great
opportunity to test what sort of live
events will resonate with your player
base so that you can create the content
that your players will want to perceive
it is also important to consider how
different forms of testing can be used
to achieve different purposes or testing
tracks can be used in unison with each
other allowing you to target different
experiences to different groups of
testers for instance you may want to
consider to run your daily billets past
the internal test track users to check
for regressions
at the same time as you're running a
large-scale open tests with early access
close testing can also be used to find
true specific gameplay mechanics with a
select audience before rolling out to
production test users I mean your
production users finally you should
always keep in mind the mobile games
development is ever-changing landscape
new technology is opening up new ways to
play and play expectations on mobile or
ever changing remember to continuously
evaluate your processes around
development and testing see what works
what doesn't work and most importantly
do not be afraid of change with that I
like to hand over to Ignacio who is
going to talk to you about launching
games on Google Play thanks Jonathan
hi everyone I'm Ignacio I'm part of the
Play team based in London and I have the
privilege and honor to work with many
game developers like you so let's talk
about launching your game I'm pretty
sure that by now you have tested and
tested your game and you are 100%
confident or let's say at least 95
percent confident that your game is
ready both from the back-end and
front-end to receive a lot of users then
as well your customer teams are ready to
manage the community create new live
events or deal with the feedback but
above all that your game is lots of fun
and so you have a lunch date and it is
still scary right so well likely in the
play team in the Play console you have
some tools that will help you to reach
those levels of confidence and today for
the launch part we're going to talk
about three in particular we're going to
talk about device catalog you're going
to talk about pre-registration and then
last country targeting let's look at
them in further detail so device catalog
this feature it's very popular and the
reason is because it helps you make
better decisions when prioritizing bug
fixes and the
livering the right experience for each
device since launch last year we have
seen that 66% of developers are using it
on a monthly basis we all know that
Android is an incredibly rechecking
system with hundreds of manufacturers
and thousands of devices so let's turn
these into an opportunity and try to
deliver the best experience based on
relevant factors such as SOC RAM or CPU
but during this process there's one key
thing to remember which is essentially
to think big and what I mean by think
big is just let's try to include as many
devices by default as possible excluding
devices should be a temporary measure
until some of these bugs are fixed let's
look at the device detail page the
device detail page is a feature that
allows you to review individually
thousands of devices added identified
relevant criteria such as run SOC or CPU
since last year we added new filtering
methods for example screen size density
and application binary interface as well
since last year we added the unsupported
reason so you can very quickly identify
why a device isn't supported by your
game lastly I wanted to highlight also
some interesting information that the
device little page is providing
essentially the number of active devices
in this in this particular game the
average rating and the revenues
generated by inner purchases of
subscriptions in the last month so what
some of the developers are saying about
this so this is the legends a mobile
developer from Barcelona they actually
launched a very popular game responible
which was launched in 2014 and since
then they have seen more than 30 million
installs and what is more important more
than 2 billion battles played by the
players so these are Legends two or
three times a week they check the device
catalog and essentially they do three
things the first one they exclude those
devices that they do not meet the
minimum required
in order to deliver a great user
experience then second they isolate the
box and then third they prioritize
device report and as well these back
fixes so thanks to this feature this is
a legends has seen an increase in the
user experience and ratings as well on
the overall quality and performance of
the game so in conclusion I wanted to
highlight three things to remember so
the first one think big and support as
many devices as possible second if we
have to exclude some devices try to do
in a temporary way so we can fix all
those backs and increase our chances to
reach a bigger audience and then last
use the device detail page to get very
relevant information such as for example
they're supported reason or the average
revenues or average rating and with this
let's move on to the next functionality
feature pre-registration we all know
that in gaming creating excitement
before even launch is increasingly
critical and popular so the
pre-registration feature has two
benefits as a player it's clear you can
pre-register and then when the game is
launched you will receive a notification
to install the game we all know that in
certain type of games multiplayer social
games competitive games in general is
critical to have a very early or get get
on early into into the game however from
a developer perspective I can see that
there's two main benefits here the first
one is you can start marketing early and
capture the audience interest as well by
monitoring the pre rich count we have an
indication of the influx at users of
users at launch and we can plan ahead
not only from a server side but also
like marketing let's look at a case
study next one is a Korean developer and
the creator of some popular games in
particular Durango white lines which was
launched in Korea the 25th of January
2018 so they started the pre rich
process six weeks before launching the
game
and during this time they saw 2.5
million pre-registration users out of
those 2.5 million users pre-reg users
46% were coming from the plate
pre-registration feature and what is
very interesting here is that the day 7
conversion meaning from launch date
until the day seventh the first week the
conversion for play-ay pre-reg users was
about 70% which is 7 times higher than
the other sources so as Kiki human the
head of platform relation says Google
pre-registration is essentially a very
effective marketing tool so how is next
when using for other games so Nexen has
launched 20 games in 2017 and has used
the pre-registration feature in 10 games
last year 50% they saw a 50% conversion
from pre rich users to actual users
downloading these up this game they have
seen also that the CPI's are quite
lowered there's 60% lower in pre-launch
than in post launch period and as such
this has led to a decision to allocate
the marketing budget 50% to the
pre-launch stage rather than in post
launch so far the pre-registration pilot
has been very successful in 2017 we've
seen numbers such as more than 50
developers using this functionality as
well 200 million players registering and
a hundred million players actually
downloading those games and then a total
of four hundred lounges across both
small and big developers indeed this is
exciting but what is even more exciting
is to know that today we are announcing
that pre rich is becoming available to
all developers very soon so what are
they some of the things that we need to
take into account if we want to have a
good experience with pre rich so three
things as well that I wanted to remember
so the first is allow some time to build
the excitement so in between three to
six weeks it's enough in order to gather
all this audience interest but as well
use all the channels that you have
available you know
to build that excitement for example
media communities forms your own website
and across all these channels make sure
that you have a clear action in this
code in this case pre-register in Google
Play with this in mind let's jump into
the last tool which is country targeting
country targeting is a very powerful
tool and essentially it allows two
things so first we can have different
tracks per country and then we can run
separate closed-open tests or production
in a specific geography this is very
useful as a quote mentions for soft
launches in processes where for example
we want to have one particular region in
production to test user acquisition or
monetization secondly is key during
launch because we can use a staged
rollout per geographies and these means
that you can control the rollout in
different countries and then monitor
which users are getting into the app
this allows us to test server
performance or user feedback so let's
look at how some developers are using
this functionality so wargaming
Ukrainian developer and behind the game
world of warship blitz they launched
this game in January 2018 as well and
the game has already seen more than 3
million instance in Google Play by the
way a hundred millions ships destroyed
and more than fifteen millions played
shut down so incredible numbers as well
on that side and we spoke with Raymond
sharing which is the marketing who is
the marketing manager in wargaming and
he told us that they use the country
targeting during the soft launch period
the soft launch period took about six
months and they divided in three stages
so the first states they select a few
number of countries and there was
testing things like stability so crash
rates monetization lifetime value and
CPI and then engagement which is user
engagement and duration of the games on
a second stage they open up to a fewer
more countries and they were testing
mostly server capacity and ensuring the
stability of the game and then on a
third stage there were
open up to already more countries across
all continents with the intent of
testing monetization mostly so lastly
during this whole process wargaming was
testing as well and monitoring the
ratings and the reviews and reacting
based on the user feedback
so in conclusion regarding country
targeting two things to remember today
so the first one is like we can use a
country targeting during soft launch but
also during the open and closed best at
beta test processes as well as during
even like future updates or post launch
period and the second thing is at launch
plant ahead what is going to be the
rollout to the different countries so as
far as in all the world can download the
game and enjoy it quickly but without
any issues and with these I would like
to call my colleague David thank you
[Applause]
thanks Ignacio I'm David product manager
on play console go to market tools and
Google Play game services now we're
moving on to post launch at this point
you've developed your game tested with a
growing cohort of testers had a good
launch day and a strong launch week and
the dust of the settling what are the
things that you're gonna be thinking
about next three post launch activities
that we're gonna focus on are growing
your audience to get as many people as
possible
playing your great game engaging your
players by delivering a great experience
they want to keep coming back to and
earning money so you can keep running
your game or build your next one let's
start with audience growth players are
becoming harder and more expensive to
acquire and retain game developers like
you are using lots of different
strategies to acquire users UA is common
but so are other less trackable methods
cross-promotion and other games
leveraging youtube influencers utilizing
social channels third-party website
marketing I'm sure you have other great
methods to you can track clicks and
installs from ads but players who
install your app organically from the
Play Store who may get their say via
search after reading about your game on
a third-party website our black box
while accounting for the majority of
installs for most developers using the
new tools in organic acquisition
insights report in play console you can
see the breakdown of how many new
installers have accessed your listing
either via search or by browsing the
Play Store most users find games in
google play using search and with this
tool you can dive deeper into search and
see the specific search terms that drive
users to your game
organic acquisition insights reports is
coming soon for all developers the
developers we've talked to are excited
to use these insights in order to assess
their acquisition strategies change
their store listing and screenshot to
reflect what their users are looking for
and even optimize in-app onboarding
experiences to ensure the
references the features and benefits
that the users find most appealing this
is a powerful new tool that I hope
you'll explore to find out more about
organic acquisition insights you can go
to this talk tomorrow morning next we'll
talk about Google Play instant growing
your game involves getting users excited
about it and a great way to do that is
to give them a quick and easy way to
experience it for quick background we
launched in synapse
at i/o last year and since then we've
been very busy there are more than a
billion devices that support in synapse
and we've improved our tooling to make
building and snaps even easier and as
you may have heard we now that we're
bringing in synapse to games at GDC six
weeks ago and those of today Google Play
incident is now available to all game
developers so why should you consider
making an instant game instant games
allow players to try your game before
installing it and make it easy to
install the full game at the end of the
instant game experience using the
install prompt API being able to try a
game before installing is a hit with
players and after publishing their
instant game mighty battles has seen a
19 percent increase in acquisition rate
so what's the difference between in
snaps and instant games what we've done
is adapt the instant app frameworks so
what better needs the may meets the
needs of DM developers like you there
are three things we've changed we've
increased the size limit to 10 megabytes
we've enabled progressive download of
executable code and assets using the
splits in this always API and very
importantly we've added full support for
native code and are integrating with
game engines and OpenGL this means you
can use the same code base and tools as
your full game to build your instant
game and by creating an instant game you
open up a lot of surfaces players can
experience instant games directly from
ads in the play games app arcade via
link you can send with a messaging app
and of course in the Play Store while
we're on the topic of Google Play
Instant we
to touch back just for a moment on
launching tools pre-reg is very
successful program and we're bringing
the instant games to play stores
pre-registration feature now players
that pre-register can get a sneak
preview of your game and when you
promote pre-registration through social
media email or on your website users
will be able to play instantly from any
Android device it's an awesome way to
introduce your game to the world to
learn more about instant games you can't
end this session on Thursday next we'll
look at engagement Android vitals is
designed to help you identify issues at
scale so you can create a better more
fluid more optimized and more engaging
experience for your players there are a
number of new vitals features launching
including benchmarks for all vitals and
new vitals including startup time which
were discussed the Android vital session
earlier this afternoon a particular
interest for game developers like you
are stability and battery vitals
stability vitals include ANR's and
crashes and batteries include stock way
clocks and excessive wake up's
we are now showing these vitals against
a bad behavior threshold exhibiting bad
behavior and vitals will negatively
infect the user experience in your game
and can result in bad ratings and poor
discoverability in the Play Store we
also have vitals for rendering and
startup time though these are
informative at this point and with the
new vitals benchmarks you can see how
you stack up against similar games it's
important to note that at android vitals
is a powerful tool not just for app
developers but for game developers to
using vitals game developer Kalu whose
game subway surfers just passed 1
billion installs on Google Play was able
to make drastic improvements to their an
hour rate reducing it from around 2% to
below 0.1% so to help you ensure your
users enjoy playing your game how did
you two be thinking about using vitals
in your day to day keep an eye on ANR's
crashes wakelocks and wake ups which
will be easier with the notifications
and allure
it's built into play console and use the
vitals dashboard as part of your toolkit
to chase down problems now we wanted to
share with you something we've been
working on it's not ready for general
consumption yet that's coming but we
were excited to be working to bring live
ops to play we are creating new
experiences in the store and in the play
games app to show players the events
that are happening now in their games
this is proving very popular with
players and we're going to continue
exploring in this direction and finally
let's move on to Revenue Google Play has
had subscriptions since 2012 where
they've mostly been the domain of
subscription for access apps games
typically monetize through AI APs and
ads or are paid games but a number of
developers have been experimenting with
subscriptions and we wanted to share
their experiences you may be wondering
what's the business case of adding
subscriptions when I already have AI ap
developers who implemented subscriptions
or port an increase in engagement and
retention not just for the subscribers
but for their overall user base as well
as you can see from monster strikes
experience with Mon Pass many including
scope Li also notice minimal
cannibalization of AI AP resulting in
incremental gains to overall revenue
driven by both subscriptions and I ap
another developer who's found successful
subscriptions is network in legendary
game of Heroes they use subscriptions
for the VIP loyalty program this program
has proved popular with players as you
can see has created a new revenue stream
for legendary game heroes with strong
positive impact on overall revenue there
are two best practices and using
subscriptions to provide value to
players loyalty programs for your high
value users and a new access point to
premia experience for traditional non
buyers the target audience will
influence how you choose to design your
offering some examples of a VIP loyalty
program features include exclusive or
exclusive or early access to content
special in-game VIP status and title or
a bonus
out with each purchase this is the most
popular subscription design we've seen
so far and as you can see from Lou Diaz
Jurassic world the game implement here
developers have also found that
subscriptions can be effective in
converting traditional non buyers these
players are motivated by getting a good
financial deal you can see network's
implementation here which is a VIP
loyalty program aimed at these
traditional on buyers of course as with
any monetization system be aware of
potential downsides and keep a closed
pulse of fair player feedback and
community sentiment to help you with
your subscription program Google Play
has a very robust subscriptions
infrastructure with a lot of rich
features we support you with billing
tools and analytics insight reports
throughout the entire user funnel and we
can take care of you civil subscription
features such as flexible billing free
trials account hold so you can focus on
testing and implementing an effective
in-game subscription design to learn
more about subscriptions you watch the
recording of this secession from earlier
this afternoon we've gone through some
of the tools that you can take advantage
of post-launch
but as we draw to a close I want to loop
us back to the beginning of our talk and
call out testing again it's good to
always be testing in comparison to apps
this can be tricky for games as games
some games need users to be on the same
version to function properly but think
about how you can effectively use plays
testing tracks which were all work as
well appo slog as they do pre-launch to
ensure your updates live up to the
quality bar set for your game to wrap up
we've discussed a number of tools in
play console you can use in various
stages of your games lifecycle there's a
lot going on in mobile gaming right now
with fantastic gamer growths loads of
high-quality games being released and
lost a competition it's your own fault
as you keep raising the bar higher and
higher in terms of graphics story and
gameplay all done we're excited to see
what you're able to build next and where
gaming goes from here
the tools we've talked to you through
today can help you along your journey in
a few key places and give you some
abilities and insights you can leverage
to help you succeed we'd also love to
hear your feedback on this session
thanks for your time we're around for
this today and you can also check out
the sandbox over here thank you
[Music]